[Música]
bienvenidos a todos a este programa que
dedicaremos a hablar sobre los problemas
que la pandemia de ccoo y 19 ha
acentuado y que han provocado otra
pandemia silenciosa pero igual de
peligrosa el coronavirus incremento la
ansiedad la depresión e incluso los
intentos de suicidios en muchos sectores
de la población desde que empezó la
crisis sanitaria la prioridad ha sido
salvar vidas así que las necesidades
emocionales de las personas quedaron
relegadas a un segundo plano sin embargo
esto también requiere mucha atención con
la pandemia quedó al descubierto la poca
inversión que los países hacen en lo que
se refiere a los servicios de salud
mental pero qué es la salud mental y qué
tanta inversión hacen las naciones en
este campo para saber más los invito a
ver la siguiente nota
la salud mental está intrínsecamente
relacionada con la salud física la salud
mental es un estado de bienestar que nos
permite enfrentar los problemas y
funcionar de manera productiva en la
sociedad hace parte de lo que nos hace
humanos como la forma en que
interactuamos aprendemos trabajamos y
experimentamos nuestros sentimientos con
la pandemia de kobe 19 todo esto se ha
alterado en diferentes niveles y
sectores de la población
extraña anormalidad
y bueno es
relativamente normal no saber
la semana que viene no sé si voy a poder
abrir mi negocio si tengo que ir a
trabajar si voy atrás
todo eso provoca una serie de síntomas
de ansiedad de depresión que son
relativamente normales porque estamos
reaccionando una situación excepcional
pero bueno provocar ese malestar el
aislamiento el teletrabajo la pérdida de
los vínculos sociales y del empleo son
algunos factores que han aumentado los
problemas psicológicos cuando muchas
personas no tienen acceso a un servicio
de salud mental adecuado según la
organización panamericana de la salud el
promedio del gasto en servicios de salud
mental es de apenas el 28 por ciento del
gasto total destinado a la salud a nivel
mundial los países de ingresos bajos
gastan cerca del 0 5 por ciento de su
presupuesto en servicios de salud mental
y los países de ingresos altos el 51 por
ciento datos de la organización mundial
de la salud indican que más de 300
millones de personas sufren de depresión
y más de 260 millones tienen trastornos
de ansiedad a nivel mundial uno de cada
cinco ciudadanos en américa del sur
sufre de por lo menos una enfermedad
mental este problema produce más de un
tercio de la discapacidad total en las
américas
sectores
porque nosotros permanentes psicológicos
mundiales generales
sea una buena oportunidad para abrir
y para
y abrir las puertas digamos a la
atención a salud mental
justamente como nombre origen desde la
salud mental no de la enfermedad
con la nueva realidad quedó demostrado
que los más afectados mentalmente no son
solamente los que ya soportaban un nivel
de ansiedad estrés o tensión muy alto
los trabajadores de la salud aquellos
que perdieron a un ser querido por culpa
del virus y la población más joven harta
del encierro también sufren las secuelas
de la guerra contra el 'hobbit' 19
para hablar más sobre estos temas nos
acompaña a claudio top elbert profesor
de psiquiatría de la universidad de
harvard y también el científico
investigador en el centro de niños
george baker y en el hospital de niños
en boston y además psiquiatra en jefe
del centro para niños de nueva
inglaterra
el miedo contagiaron ser contagiado el
estrés por el incremento de la carga
laboral y familiar' el insomnio la
depresión e incluso los intentos
suicidas son algunos de los síntomas que
ha desatado la pandemia de kobe 19
doctor top el ver con esta avalancha de
emociones negativas cuál podría ser la
mejor estrategia a nivel personal y las
herramientas para combatir una crisis
mental en tiempos de pandemia
te diría que hay tres categorías una vez
en lo que se llama
[Música]
conversación positiva interna positivo
en inglés la otra sería las acciones que
en una emergencia digamos pueden parar
el estrés de tener el estrés y las otras
son las cosas que en generar actividades
no se puede hacer regularmente que son
antiestrés contadas cada diez antes de
hablar o
reaccionar a un comentario y tomar
algunos respiraciones profundas y
tranquilas tratar de enlentecer el ritmo
respiratorio salir a caminar y tomar una
breve meditación o un rezo para la gente
que es religiosa si algo no es urgente
dejarlo para el día siguiente tratar de
pensar lo que la distancia entre cosas
que obligan una reacción inmediata y uno
puede pensar muchas cosas y cómo esto
puede llegar a detener la reacción de
estrés y finalmente actividades
regulares
y se ven
cristian antiestrés
y esto va a depender mucho de la
preferencia personal es muy importante
que estas actividades uno las haga lo
que se imponga supongamos leer un libro
donde no le gusta leer pero si es algo
que es la actividad que gusta leer hacer
arte hacer ejercicio jugar un deporte
inclusive comunicarse socialmente con
gente con las cuales hay una relación
positiva los grupos más vulnerables a la
pandemia son por ejemplo las personas
con pocos recursos el personal sanitario
expuesto al virus todos los días las
personas que están en prisión o que
sufren de enfermedades crónicas en fin
estos grupos son vulnerables al contagio
pero son también los más vulnerables a
las crisis mentales a causa de la
pandemia o cómo se podría analizar la
vulnerabilidad mental durante estos días
por supuesto la gente que se enferma de
colo que tiene miembros de la familia
que se enferman con kobe y esos tienen
sus propias situaciones por las cuales
están expuestos a un ricoh más alto
segunda es decir derecha si alguien
muere si alguien muere en aislamiento en
la familia y los miembros de la familia
los hijos los
familiares cercanos no pueden tener
contacto y no pueden apoyar a las
personas del período final y es
realmente campo está muy muy duro
y donde ha sido muy afectado de todos
los estudios en el grupo etario que sea
muy afectado son los adolescentes hasta
los jóvenes los adultos jóvenes digamos
el ideal y esto es aproximado por
entrada de 16 digamos y 26 tan instantes
que es que la gente
se tiende a sentar más y cuando sus
relaciones tienen una pared con una
familia ahí hay otro motivo de estrés
ahí pero donde realmente un pico y si
uno piensa la importancia de la de tener
amigos de socializar o empezar a
aprender sobre el fondo de chicas o con
varones y se transitan toda esa época de
tener esa época de edad y de trama muy
limitada es realmente estresante doctor
top al ver que hay un incremento de los
servicios de salud para tratar los
trastornos mentales por ejemplo el
gobierno en colombia activo líneas
telefónicas en venezuela varias
organizaciones ofrecen consultas como la
federación de psicólogos de venezuela e
incluso en españa existe la aplicación
móvil llamada ay fil donde los usuarios
pagan sesiones con psicólogos en fin
muchas son las opciones que hay en este
momento cree usted que el servicio de
salud mental tendrá una cobertura
universal en los sistemas de salud de
los países en un futuro cercano
bueno por supuesto
de una ideal llegar a cobertura
universal en el sentido de que todo el
mundo tenga acceso a los seguros cubren
los servicios de salud mental ese es el
caso en eeuu en eeuu ha habido un
proceso que finalmente se secuestran la
ley y los seguros los servicios de salud
mental están cubiertos por el seguro
pero argentina tienen muchos servicios
en muchos detalles y muchos servicios
públicos muchos centros de salud mental
o públicos que son disponibles mucha
gente que no tiene recursos económicos
puede acceder gratuitamente con
cobertura del seguro de acceder a la
psicoterapia medicación
y hay otros países que es sorprendente
que están relativamente tienen recursos
de otros sentidos pero absolutamente
ninguna red de salud mental desde
siempre un ejemplo que puedo dar y poner
hoy ser un de turquía que cuando tuvo
los terremotos hace unas décadas fueron
traumatizados enorme nos nombres números
de la población y de niños no tenían
sede se quedó claro
muy bien la salud que no había en vastas
áreas del país no había ningún servicio
de salud mental del hospital
psiquiátrico
y cómo por fin siquiera para que solo
todavía psicólogo robert a
psiquiatras que se entera aprendería
mucho a su tierra un poco
y todo eso llevó un gran plan de salud
mental
bueno doctor todo para ver y para
concluir cuáles cree que serán las
grandes secuelas que dejará la pandemia
en la sociedad a nivel mental y por
cuánto tiempo van a perdurar
bueno eso se habla de que la la tercera
ola epidemiológica relacionar con una
gestión ágil además alimenta va a
depender actualmente
de los otros individuos
secuelas o secuelas permanentes otra va
a ser una memoria acaba mucho una
población muy grande pero por supuesto
los que han vivido situaciones
traumáticas como resultado de como vida
aquellos que han perdido sus trabajos
sus bienes que tuvieron consecuencias
irreversibles en las relaciones
familiares que han perdido seres
queridos de aquellos que han sido
afectados y tienen unas crónicas
enfermedades que son más vulnerables a
tener trastornos persistentes
digamos desde el tipo que no se
resuelven completamente pero que son
tratables para los cuales hay
tratamientos que son y que no hay cura
digamos que hay tratamientos pongamos
que evidenciando de que estemos al año
para ser vamos por ejemplo del inquieto
en una pérdida muy grande vuelo implica
es algo que puede tomar tiempo
finalmente sufre una pérdida cromática
hoy pero no quiere sentir la tercera no
pueda mejorar con el tiempo mejora
significativamente la resolver la
situación y aquellos que tienen síndrome
postraumático vemos que fueron
traumatizados por el tratamiento médico
y ahora no pueden dormir y tienen
recuerdos de las experiencias
psicoterapéutico
y otras técnicas
ampliar
funciona la mejoría de la resolución
totalmente es esperable que haya
sectores aunque ya que eran vulnerables
va a tener impacto en salud mental que
lo sigan teniendo
doctor papel ver muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros en este
programa dedicado a la salud mental y
este los invito a que continúen nuestra
programación en france 24 y en nuestra
página france24 puntocom
[Música]